[Aplausos]
para invitar primero para comenzar antes
de que
mariana yo te voy a pedir que me ayudes
para acá te toco deja todas tus cosas
por allá y tú vente para acá
muy bien normalmente yo no iba a hablar
de internet y el valor montón de cosas
pero vamos a acá
yo quiero que usted escoja una pareja
por ahí ojalá alguien que usted no
conozca y saluda no haga real es que
usted confía agarre alguien de la gente
de atrás por favor con los de atrás
vinimos a conocer gente no solo vimos a
escuchar cosas y por favor póngase de
frente con esa persona porque se mira
ahí está un joven soltero
muy bien ya se puso de frente por esa
persona ahora por favor pongan las manos
en los hombros de esa persona muy bien
los hombros está aquí muy bien listo
hasta ahí todo perfecto muy bien ahora
usted va a mirar fijamente a los ojos de
esa persona
si se pone nervioso es porque hay clic
entonces
usted le va a decir esto esto es lo más
sencillo y esta es la persecución humana
usted o miraron somos personas usted le
va a decir te amo
por tener un abrazo muy bien y muchas
gracias por estar acá hay muchas gracias
y muy bien dibujado regales un aplauso a
usted
y siéntese y le cuento
mi pregunta es por qué nos cuesta tanto
decirle a los demás que los amamos en la
vida real
en el internet cuando hay un famoso o
hay alguien que nos agrada si le hicimos
mi amor mi vida te amo eres la cosa más
sexy del mundo
y mi pregunta es porque hemos dejado de
amar la realidad
y hemos vuelto nos hemos vuelto adictos
a cosas digitales e irreales que nos
está pasando como sociedad para que
amemos más estar en instagram en twitter
en un montón de lugares que abrazando
nuestras familias o porque la nana de
los niños está volviendo el ipad y
estamos dejando de ser papás qué está
pasando con nosotros que queremos
compartir una vida irreal que estamos
viviendo y que estamos compartiendo
ahora esto es básicamente lo que hacemos
nos reunimos seis personas en frente una
mesa supuestamente a comer y cada quien
está chateando mandando mensajes estamos
más conectados con el mundo que está
lejos que con las personas que están
cerca usted está más conectado ahorita
por whatsapp con la gente que está a
miles de kilómetros que con la persona
que usted tiene al lado
a alguien
y tener un gesto afectuoso con alguien
que usted tiene a centímetros
qué está pasando con nosotros como
humanidad para que queramos compartirlo
todo con extraños pero no queramos
compartir nada con la gente que está
cerca nuestra
qué nos está pasando que hemos dejado de
vivir y hemos dejado de experimentar
hemos dejado de ser sexuales hemos
dejado de ser románticos hemos dejado de
comer delicioso todo por andar
experimentando cosas que tienen que ver
con personas extrañas porque ahora no la
pasamos escuchando a los extraños y
bones un restaurante primero le tomamos
la foto a la comida
mandamos a instagram estamos más
pendiente cuánta gente le da
es muy tonto
o muchas veces ustedes vean las parejas
sentadas románticamente y tomando fotos
y no
y no se hablan durante la cena
es el mundo que estábamos viviendo y es
el mundo que le estamos enseñando a los
niños a vivir un
al lleno de mentiras porque además las
fotos de la comida los celulares les
hagan preciosas pero el plato
comida bien feo y bien desagradable pero
usted está bien o por ejemplo comparte
fotos de star boxing la gente no le
gusta el café de starbucks pero qué
culto marsé una foto con el vasito
starbucks
o en los conciertos la gente va a los
conciertos a ver un concierto a través
de una pantalla entonces hace poco en un
concierto de the killers en la ciudad
méxico estábamos ahí y todo en las
pantallas y yo le dije a un chico dije
oye porque no es el concierto dijo es
que mis amigos lo querían ver y yo pues
que pagan en él
o sea es lo mínimo que puede hacer
alguien que quiere venir a ver el
concierto
pero estamos más preocupados por
compartir cosas para satisfacer a otros
que ser felices nosotros ya no
disfrutamos la comida ya no necesitamos
la compañía de las personas cercanas ya
no disfrutamos los conciertos que son de
las cosas más cool
y todo porque pues qué tiene de malo es
divertido es divertido compartir es
divertido sobre una foto y que me den
like me sube autoestima pues te un
psicólogo si no tienes la autoestima
pero deja de buscar y tenemos que
empezar a dejar de buscar en los otros
lo que tenemos a un metro de distancia
en la casa
ojalá y nos sigan muchos
algunos datos muy interesantes que
encontré estoy escribiendo un libro de
este tema porque yo hago marketing
digital yo médico
así que devolver los adictos todavía lo
sigo haciendo por una manera mucho más
responsable porque empecé a encontrar
esto hay 2000 millones de niños adultos
obesos en el mundo estamos hablando que
eso es un tercio de la población mundial
simplemente hoy en día usted no se tiene
que levantar
si usted tiene hambre tiene
newbery 2 tiene
entonces ustedes
y si usted tiene que ir al lugar un
lugar no pues ya que va a caminar pues
pidamos schubert
y yo que voy a visitar a mi abuela pues
mejor la llamo
skype
y todo el tiempo estamos buscando las
maneras de volvernos cada vez más pérez
y por eso nos estamos volviendo más
gordos
huevones
pero aparte de eso el 80% de los niños
que hoy en día tienen entre 5 y 12 años
van a ser obesos
quiero que mis hijos sean los cortitos e
ir rodando
pero eso y eso me empezó a hacer
preguntarme donde yo he visto esas cosas
porque esa realidad está así yo trabajé
en barcos y otros en cruceros y me
y cuenta que había algo ahí y encontré
esto que me pareció más grave que la
obesidad estamos dejando de tener
relaciones sexuales por el internet
porque vivimos tan ocupados que ya ni
siquiera
las marcas a nuestra pareja tenemos
tiempo
porque estamos más preocupados por qué
va a pasar con la mamá de luis miguel
que por nuestra familia y nuestra pareja
y tontos entonces esta investigación de
cambridge dice que en el 2030 casi va a
ser nula nuestra sexualidad
disfrutarla poniendo los límites el
internet
vamos a dejar de reproducir cortos y sin
reproducir los gordos feos y sin
reproducir nos gravísimo terrible y yo
dije donde vi esto entonces me acordé de
cuando yo trabaja en cruceros que yo
empezaba a ver a la gente que tiene
obesidad que llega en carritos si han
visto los supermercados en eeuu más que
todo y me di cuenta que pasaba esto en
una película futurista grant wahl y
todos vamos a hacer como wali conectados
a una pantalla cortos estúpidos y si nos
dicen que la moda roja
por más chistoso que sea ésa es nuestra
desgraciada realidad
pero es que eso no está pasando
he encontrado muchos en supermercados
encontrado muchos en restaurantes que
los papás porque el niño no llore y deje
de ser niño le dan una para todos esos
el otra caminando una señora carrión
laboriosa que estas fotos con el ipad el
bebé
privando a los niños la posibilidad de
ver el mundo de ver un perro de ver un
árbol de ver un pajarito de ver a una
pareja peleándose en la calle de echar
chisme
les estamos quitando la posibilidad de
ser humanos e interactuar con su entorno
por interactuar con un entorno digital
que no es real
el internet sea malo el internet es una
maravilla pero nuestra vida no puede
depender como los gorditos de wally 100%
de la tecnología
tenemos que ser un cambio enorme pero se
cambió nosotros por qué porque yo
también era un gordito de walt y
conectado a la tecnología todo el día
trabajando de 18 horas al día en una
agencia de marketing digital engordando
tenía 25 kilos más de peso de los que
tengo ahorita
pidiendo comida todo el tiempo por apps
y completamente digitalizado en mis
relaciones de amigos de pareja de
familia todo
y lo más triste entonces que uno empieza
a engordar y no saca su celular yo no
dice
gordito así
para verse bien en la foto pero entonces
aparte de cortitos que nos estamos
volviendo que no era una contra la
gordura porque hay cliente que tiene
problemas de salud por eso pero es un
problema que nosotros estamos generando
nos porque yo me lo genere y aparte nos
volvemos mentirosos y terminamos siendo
esto no en instagram o nativa súper
linda si en la vez real no podemos no
nos caro el botón de la camisa explotan
los botones de la camisa
y también estamos generando a los niños
a los jóvenes una expectativa de ser
sexo y des y de ser guapos que no
necesitan
el internet es la prueba de que el
acceso a la información no era el
problema porque los ochentas y noventas
decíamos es que la televisión solamente
lo manejan ciertos impresos y
somos tontos en el internet hay una
cantidad de información pero que más se
consume es pornografía
hay un montón de información pero la
gente sabe más cómo ver en wikipedia lo
de luisito rey
buscar cursos gratis para programar o
para hacer fotografía lo que sea
no hay universidad gratuita más grande
del mundo que youtube usted pone
como este para mi esposo y que no centre
en mis vecinas hay tutoriales para todo
hay tutores en youtube es fabuloso pero
nosotros somos los que estamos tomando
malas decisiones como sociedad no es el
internet no es el mundo somos cada uno
de nosotros como individuos los que
estamos completamente desconectados de
esa realidad
y todos sabemos y este es el mundo que
nosotros estamos construyendo un mundo
lleno de fe news noticias falsas
noticias falsas por todos lados cierto
de las elecciones presidenciales que
hubo en méxico y en colombia vimos
noticias falsas
todas las que quieran pero lo más
chistoso es que no entre las
compartíamos
entonces veíamos un portal que se
llamaba el doctor pachuca noticias
erradas punto camino no pero es que mi
tía me lo mandó mí que a través del
portal
cuenta que esas falsas noticias eran
especulaciones económicas le crean daño
a la gente
que alguien crear en eso
noticia falsa de usted
somos opinólogos estamos en un mundo
lleno de opinólogos entonces hay quien
pone algo de economía y todo el mundo sí
pero
y no sabemos a veces ni sumarlo
cosas que no sabemos
la vida de los demás y cuando alguien
pone una foto en internet de que se fue
de viaje ahí está
hemos vuelto un montón de idiotas
famosos
y eso es lo que nuestros hijos y lo que
nosotros consumimos en el día
lo que más se comparte en internet son
bromas
hay gente que se dedica a hacer bromas
con dulce o al trabajo y le echan
baldados de agua les han confeti y le
echan espuma
y respeto sólo tiene
es gracioso
o también los niños que se meten
condones por la boca y por la nariz y se
los sacan
volver a los idiotas famosos
pero esta es la base de lo que usted
compra
odio
nos eleva a un equipo de fútbol y el
otro otro tiene que haber odio en
internet tenemos que compartir memes y
cosas que quieran al otro
o si alguien cometió un error y lo
grabamos en internet tenemos que
compartirlo entre todos para destruir la
vida una niña que se emborrachó y
estrelló un carro
porque son
maravilla y por los seres humanos
tenemos el poder de comunicar
también podría ser vulnerable
y una cosa que nos damos cuenta es que
generamos una mala competencia
el mundo que estamos basando en internet
se basa en la mala competencia en cual
niñas más bueno ahora para que la sigan
más gente
en cual hombre es más idiota para que lo
siguió más gente
probablemente sus hijos han dicho yo
quiero ser youtube
y pasa mucho y pasa mucho porque no
estamos informando también de lo que
pasa
mundo quieres tú dejarle a tus hijos y
que el mundo te quieres tú dejar a ti
mismo
que tú compartes en el día a día
es un vivo reflejo lo que tú eres como
persona
y me gusta cuando hay silencio cuando yo
veo que la gente empieza a pensar
y vamos a conectarlos con la vida y me
encanta que haya gente que ya haya
dejado el celular guardado en la bolsa
es transmitir en internet
no se pierda los cinco minutos de sol
no se pierda codearse con el otro para
pelearse por el récord
no se pierda caminar no pierda caerse
este cubito le contaba que una
presentación de unos niños y está en la
primera fila y pues los niños además hoy
día como que no le echan ganas a nada
muchos porque son todos como deprimidos
viven los niños ahora
y yo le digo yo no está mirando lo que
decía ninguno tiene cicatrices en las
rodillas
yo siempre alguno de mis amiguitos
siempre tenía un morado en las rodillas
y estaba y no pueda caminar pero
ahora los niños no tienen rodillas
raspadas
o la medicina avanzado mucho
que no lo creo nos hemos vuelto muy
tontos pero somos nosotros los que
estábamos haciendo eso somos nosotros
los que construimos ese mundo
y este es un dato que me parece terrible
que los niños
menores de 25 años
le habló muy bien sufren ciberacoso
tiene
la probabilidad de suicidarse o
lesionarse casi un 50% más que otro niño
porque porque como lo estamos viendo
tontos competitivos como lo estamos
volviendo sin criterio como estamos
haciendo todo este tipo de cosas aquí
hay un par de mamás blogueras que
conozco y con las que hemos tocado estos
temas y con gente con la que trabajamos
en internet y es gravísimo el ciberacoso
muchas veces el ciberacoso se genera
muchas veces si hubiera cosas de general
que nosotros le promovemos a una niña de
12 años que sea la mujer más sexy del
planeta tierra
y como no los común no cumple las
expectativas de su sociedad la vamos a
ir a maltratar
cuando un chico se estrella borracho
como muchos alguna vez en la vida lo
hicieron cuando eras jóvenes
pero para que su juventud y la mía está
oculta porque no teníamos ese acceso a
viralizar información pero los chicos
están suicidando porque este dicho
compartimos contenido de ellos que no
deberíamos
punto es que vamos a hacer como sociedad
para esto hay mirarme a mí
se me acabó ya mi presentación
y la cosa es que nos merecemos un mejor
internet usted y yo nos merecemos un
mejor internet pero ante todo en esta
vida nos merecemos una mejor vida y
muchísimo más real muchas gracias
[Aplausos]